as memorial day weekend there's many
gearing up for a trip to lake mead it's
expected to be quite busy especially
with limited ramp usage joe moeller went
out there today to show us some of the
dangers at the lake you really need to
be aware of
this this time of low water we've
it's just we've had so many problems
with temperatures going up in the
holiday weekend here
lake mead will be bustling really be
attentive you know have people looking
around the water is the lowest it has
ever been the first intake you can see
the top of it there more is surfacing
like this sunken boat but something
boaters need to remember is the water is
more shallow in places it's a concern
for deputy ranger matt stark like there
are little fingers that pop up and those
are things that you know in years past
you may be able to have driven full
plane you know past there no problem
but this year you know you're going to
have a prop strike you're going to run
aground lake mead is down to one boat
ramp the first time there has been only
one for memorial day weekend we have one
launch ramp on lake mead compared to the
six that we had last year kelsey larson
with the park service says the ramp that
is open is hemingway harbor three launch
locations on lake mojave are still
stable it's important to stay hydrated
and don't operate a boat under the
influence another concern from ranger
trooper snow don't take your pool floats
out on the lake we've had 40 drownings
over the last five years 15 of those are
directly attributed towards pull toys
boaters like warren murphy know the lake
has changed more little islands out
there that you've never seen before he
says boaters should take it slow but
when you get close to the site you just
look for a little lighter color in the
water and take it easy again with the
amount of rams that are closed here on
lake mead officials say if you are
planning to come out here pack your
patience and get here as soon as you can
because it could take several hours to
get your boat in the water reporting on
lake me joe moulder live local now